[Música]
vamos ahora las noticias de la economía
con Jorge Hurtado Jorge Buenos días para
usted Buenos días Ángela qué gusto verte
por aquí estos días ahora eso le iba a
decir que Buenos días y que bienvenido
Pues a la jornada de la mañana los
madrugadores la favorita pues mire Jorge
vamos a comenzar en Europa donde se
realiza el foro anual del Banco Central
europeo cuéntenos que se discutirá en
esta reunión bueno iban a centrar el
debate principalmente en la
estabilización macroeconómica y también
en la inflación que por supuesto Aún es
volátil tras años de la pandemia desde
este lunes y hasta el miércoles se
reunirán gobernadores representantes de
otras instituciones y también académicos
para discutir sobre la inflación las
perturbaciones de la oferta y la
política monetaria recordemos que hace
apenas dos semanas El Banco Central
europeo anunció una subida de esos tipos
de interés en un cuarto de Punto y los
llevó hasta el 4% es el nivel más alto
que han tenido desde la adopción del
euro la cita también comienza con las
intervenciones inaugurales de la
presidenta del bcbc Christine y también
de la subdirectora gerente del fondo
monetario internacional guita opinat la
localidad de sintra que está cerca de
Lisboa acoge desde el año 2013 este foro
que simula el modelo de la Fed
estadounidense que se realiza desde 1978
en Jackson Hall los mercados se fijarán
en los acontecimientos macroeconómicos y
en la orientación de los bancos
centrales y un dato clave el índice de
precios al consumo de la eurozona que se
va a publicar el viernes de esta semana
y por supuesto que esto nos da pie para
hablar de los indicadores Así es vamos a
iniciar en Europa las acciones europeas
cayeron con los valores de defensa a la
cabeza de los descensos tras el motín en
Rusia durante el fin de semana mientras
que los valores financieros se vieron
arrastrados por la creciente
preocupación de que los tipos de interés
mundiales siguen subiendo y en Asia el
índice de referencia japonés nikkei
perdió casi un 0,3% y terminó en
32.698 puntos después del revolcón que
hubo en este fin de semana el petróleo
avanzó bueno Esto tomando en cuenta que
Rusia es uno de los mayores productores
mundiales de petróleo el club
estadounidense West Texas y los futuros
del crudo brent ganaron hasta un 1,3% en
las primeras operaciones asiáticas
aunque ya comienzan a estabilizarse en
la bolsa el sábado se evitó este
enfrentamiento entre Moscú y el Grupo
Mercenario Wagner tras un acuerdo que
detuvo su rápido avance hacia la capital
rusa los analistas de gold creen que los
mercados se mueven en torno a la idea de
que esta volatilidad interna en Rusia
provoca interrupciones del suministro
Aunque el impacto en los precios podría
ser limitado también por otro factor los
temores de una recesión global debido a
las continuas subidas de los tipos de
interés ayudan de cierta forma a
equilibrar cualquier presión al alza en
los precios del petróleo bueno hablando
de temas para controlar la recesión en
China El Banco Central fijó el tipo de
cambio del medio oficial esto hizo que
el Joan chino se debilitara frente al
dólar en máximos de siete meses el Banco
Popular de China fijó el tipo de cambio
en 7,20 yuanes por dólar ante antes de
la apertura del mercado una fijación más
fuerte Envía una señal al mercado de que
el Banco Central y los responsables
políticos están observando los
movimientos de Divisas del yuan según
los expertos el yuan se ha visto
afectado por el lento crecimiento
económico de China y también el amplio
diferencial de los tipos de interés
entre Estados Unidos y China los
inversores ahora observarán la fijación
oficial del resto de la semana para
tener Claridad si se avecina algún tipo
de mayor intervención de parte del
gobierno chino que eventualmente tendría
su impacto negativo Neón bien me gusta
que ahora podamos hablar un poco de
América Latina Perú decidió destinar 54
millones de dólares para el ejército con
el objetivo de combatir el fenómeno del
niño bueno este fin de semana se aprobó
este decreto de urgencia para el
Ministerio de defensa del decreto Busca
financiar la adquisición de equipos
mecánicos de ingeniería vehículos de
soporte logístico y también equipos de
soporte técnico para dar respuesta y
reducir los daños el impacto que podría
provocar este fenómeno del niño hace dos
semanas ese país decretó estado de
emergencia en 18 de sus 25 regiones
durante 60 días por el riesgo de lluvias
intensas que trae este fenómeno en
Colombia también el gobierno dijo que
estudia decretar emergencia económica y
social por la llegada de este fenómeno
en regiones como la guajira
Este es un tema que nos va a tener
ocupados durante al menos todo este año
Jorge y cambiando de tema el consumo de
estupefacientes se mantiene alto en todo
el mundo esto nos lo dice un informe
mundial sobre drogas de 2023 que fue
elaborado por Naciones Unidas qué datos
nos tiene bueno el informe destaca una
oferta récord y también un gran auge de
las drogas
sintéticas según la ONU la cantidad
estimada de consumidores de drogas pasó
de 240 millones en 2011 a 296 millones
en 2021 esto es un 5,8% de la población
global de entre 15 y 64 años de edad y
también representa un 23% más de los
consumidores que había hace una década
el estudio revela que alrededor de medio
millón de personas murieron en 2019
debido al consumo de drogas un
17,5% más que hace una década el impacto
de las drogas en el mundo según la ONU
dice que casi 40 millones de personas
padecen trastornos por el consumo de
drogas pero solo una de cada cinco
recibe algún tipo de tratamiento
Asimismo refleja el auge de las drogas
sintéticas que tienen ventaja para los
grupos criminales son más baratas y
también su fabricación es más sencilla
por ejemplo unas 80.000 personas
murieron por sobredosis de opioides en
Estados Unidos en 2021 eso es un 60% más
que en 2019 y la mayoría de estas
muertes unas 70 mil se atribuyen a
opioides farmacéuticos sintéticos
principalmente el fentanilo escuchando
estas cifras no le parece increíble que
todavía estemos en una discusión tan
conservadora sobre la manera de combatir
el consumo de drogas ilegales es
interesante sobre todo en países de
América Latina donde también se producen
este tipo de drogas hay un gran debate
sobre el efecto que tiene la lucha
contra las drogas que deja muchísima
violencia sobre todo en las regiones
Pues fíjese la semana pasada se hundió
algo tan básico como el consumo
recreativo de marihuana en Colombia
interesante y así estamos Muchísimas
gracias Jorge y nos vemos en la próxima
hora para más noticias